[Music]  she just has to evolve she has to get  used to sitting there Megan McCain isn't  feeling Sherri Shepherd's unsolicited  advice which super bummed out when I saw  her saying that Shepherd a former view  co-host appeared on watch what happens  live with Andy Cohen and dished on how  she thinks current view co-host McCain  is doing on the show I think she has not  take the hold Republican world on her  shoulders too much right take that yeah  it's like you are not the Republican  voice I know and so it makes you stress  makes you tense and so I think you know  being able to just lighten up a little  just days later the conservative TV  personality appeared on the same show  and revealed the comedian's words didn't  sit well with her we're a new show now  and it's not the show that she once  hosted and right now and that's week  this too heavy but in Trump's America we  shouldn't be telling women to lighten up  the serious time we can take things  seriously  [Music]  [Applause]